maybe i just stick to this
right is it better okay
um okay so so that's unfortunate so so
okay so this is what i was just talking
about right you have this
image here you have a cat and this cat
is put into a neural network and the
neural network basically decides whether
it's a cat or a dog
right so far so good and in most um
applications what what you can basically
see
is whether it's a cat or dog or maybe
you can see the probability with which
the neural network um thinks
that this is a cat so maybe this neural
network thinks it's with 0.8 probability
a cat and with 0.2 probability a dog
but that's really it right there's no
more information
that you will get out of this and
so from this um you may ask the question
yeah
but but why does the neural network
think it's a
it's a cat right i mean if you if you
ask a human
for example my three year old son he
would tell you well
you know it has the eyes or
the ears or something like this and it
really looks like a cat
and and this is really not a question
that the neural network typically will
allow you to answer and and that's true
for
a lot of classifiers out there basically
but i mean like if you if you think
about it more mathematically than
okay i mean a neural network is just
some affine linear transformations and
then you apply some non-linearities
element-wise so you could say
well okay i have this neural network
here and
and i just chuck in some data and it
runs
runs through the network and i could
just look at all the hidden units right
and that would give me the answer right
it would
explain me why the neural network thinks
that this is a cat but the problem is
it's it's
it's just not useful right i mean you
get this
humongous amount of numbers
and uh you look at it and it's basically
not useful for you at all i mean
okay so um this is basically where
explainable machine learning comes in or
some people say
explainable ai um i don't like this term
because i don't like the term ai but
but um basically um this is
what the whole field is about you try to
come up with some approximative schemes
which allow you to answer
these questions they allow you to
basically infer
why the neural network makes the
decision it makes
and there are various strategies to do
this and i just gonna
discuss the most popular one probably um
which is
something called local explanations or
also known as
heat maps sometimes explanation maps is
another term that you may have heard
and the the basic idea here is um so to
so i just gonna explain this on on this
example here basically so we have an
a jet from the cipher 10
image data set and we train some
classifier to classify
on on c410 and
and now basically explanation methods
these local explanation methods they
produce you
something called the heat map which is
displayed on the right
and this heat map is basically
assigning heat to pixels which are
really relevant
in some sense for the classification
result
so if a pixel is highlighted by rat
if it's assigned heat then it was very
relevant for the classification
and so you can look at this and say well
okay it is a jet
it's classifying it this jet as a plane
because it has some cockpit
there are wings and so forth
and so um now there are a lot of ways to
generate these heat maps
um so um i don't have time to go through
them
all but i i just gonna give you one
example of how to produce them which is
probably the most simple one and also
the most naive one but
it's also the one that i can explain
very quickly so
i gotta stick to this and the basic idea
here is
um so you take the classifier and we're
just gonna call it the classifier
we're gonna call it g for now for
concreteness
and then you calculate the probability
that this is a plane
and then you differentiate this
probability with respect to the input
because you can just do with like normal
deep learning libraries
and auto grad basically you just
differentiate with back prop
with respect to the inputs it's a little
bit different to
normal neural network training where you
differentiate the network with respect
to the weights
but it's basically the same underlying
arithmetic
and and then you get some kind of result
which has the same shape as the input
right because you are differentiating a
function
which gives you a scalar output the
probability that this is a plane with
respect to the input so it's a
it's a it's an object which has the same
shape
as as the input
and um then you can visualize this
with the heat map what you typically do
is you just sum the absolute values
in each colored channel and and you get
you get this heat map
that's that's the basic idea um
now this is just the most naive way of
doing this in the most naive explanation
method
there is now a lot of literature on the
subject to come up with some kind of
explanation methods and and this is for
example a recent book
which summarized the current state of
the field
which you can check out i also want to
point out that
now these methods are really
incorporated into
deep learning frameworks so for example
pytorch recently
had this new addition to its ecosystem
which is called captain
and it's really just a a tool a set of
a library for for calculating
um these kind of heat maps and so
as a result it's now very easy to deploy
these explanation methods
in practice and it's going to be
interesting to see
i mean particularly for me as a
researcher how this is actually
applied in the field right in reality
and i would be curious to hear if some
of you
are working on this
yeah so so maybe um
you asked you have asked yourself the
question so why is this
even interesting why why is it
interesting to have
explanations and i i just want to give
you a quick list
of things that i i just came up with
there may be other reasons out there but
this is something that i
personally find interesting so one is
just debugging
often these machine learning tools don't
work in the way we would
expect them to work and so this is just
a tool in your arsenal additional tool
in your arsenal to
you know detect what could be the
underlying reason for this misbehavior
another one is feedback to users and
in order to understand this and this is
a really important issue i think
just imagine that you're a bank and you
you have some credit assignment problem
where your customers come to you and
they want to have a loan and you have
some kind of algorithm
which gives a score of whether or not
you should grant a
customer alone and so
normally you just get back a score right
but you
like for a user it may be important to
know why
he or she got a really bad score right
for example
you know you get it would be great to
get back like some kind of feedback
where you
where you get told well maybe you should
make you more more money you know your
salary is not high enough or something
like that
and by doing so by providing these kind
of
feedbacks you can hope that you
increase the trust of the users in your
bank and in your algorithm
right because it makes the whole
decision process more transparent
and then the last reason which is
getting very important these days is
that
these explanations are increasingly
required by law there's now a regulation
by the european union which goes under
the name of
write to explain which basically says
that any
automated or algorithmic
decision process has to provide some
kind of explanation
uh with it and so if you deploy neural
networks
for example you you need to answer this
question
in the foreseeable future and right now
there's still some loopholes
in this law so it's not enforced in
practice but
the european union is very much working
on revising this legislation and
then this will be a legal issue
okay so especially considering the last
three
points um you may ask the question so
good you have shown me these heat maps
right they are in some sense an
explanation
but can i actually trust these
explanations
and trusting by trusting i hear me
i mean basically can they be manipulated
and do they faithfully represent
um some kind of information about the
underlying algorithmic decision making
process
these are two questions that you may ask
right
you just get presented with this heat
map so does it
have any you know information in it that
you can trust
and this is basically the research
question that uh i've
been focusing on one of the research
questions that i have been focusing on
for the last
year or so and um and this is what i
gonna
talk about in the rest of my talk and
and try to
convince you that um you should take
these explanation
methods with a little bit of caution um
it's certainly not something that you
should just take at face
value and just simply trust it
okay so um
i've basically written two papers about
this
over the last year one was at neurips
last year
and called explanations can be
manipulated and
geometry is to plane to blame and the
other one was at icml just
this year um so just uh a few weeks ago
and um so i cannot summarize both of
them i
i basically gonna focus on the first one
because it's just
very recent and basically follow-up on
the first
but if time permits i will briefly
sketch what was done in
the other paper
okay so um
basically um what we have shown in this
paper
is the following result and i'm just
gonna summarize
the result on one slide and then i'm
gonna explain to you
give you some examples of of what the
result means in practice
and i'm going to explain to you a little
bit how we arrived at that result
because you know there's some theory and
some some theoretical understanding
behind this it's not
just experiments
so basically what we have shown and and
so you need to stick with me i
i gonna try to explain this carefully
but um
yeah it's a little bit complicated on
first side maybe
so basically what we have shown is that
for any model g
that you can give me right
i can construct another model g turtle
and this model d twill has the following
properties
so first it has identical behavior
on the data so for example in the c410
image classification result all the
classification results on all
data samples of c410 would be the same
and even more so also the class scores
would be the same so the probabilities
with which the network thinks this is a
plane would be
the same and also all the you know not
only the winning class but also the sub
winning classes
would have the same probabilities so
exactly same output on all of the data
right but you can provide me
with a target explanation for any given
data sample
and i can modify the the
the classifier to this g-turtle such
that it closely
reproduces this target explanation man
so basically you can arbitrarily draw an
explanation and i can
manipulate the classifier in such a way
that it has this explanation
but that that the underlying decisions
that are made are exactly the same
that's that's the the basic idea so
let me illustrate this in an in an
example
um so here we we take the classic of
machine learning like the classic task
of machine learning
uh mnist we all love uh love good old
and list and
and so what we have here is basically a
nine from the mnus data set and we train
some
some classifier g on mnist
and it classifies all the digits as you
would expect
and then we run some heat map uh some
explanation method to produce these heat
maps
and here you see an example in the lower
uh left hand corner uh for an
explanation for the original model g
right just some explanation that shows
you that somehow the closed
loop is really important for the
classification results
and now we run our manipulation method
and we take this original model g and we
transform it to a manipulated model
g twiddle and this manipulated
model g twiddle classifies all the
digits in exactly the same manner it has
the same probabilities that
this number is a nine but as its
explanation we have specified it to have
the explanation of a 42 which we just
drew i
i literally drew this an ms paint i i
know
but you know that's not the perfect tool
but
and and so we can manipulate the model
such that
it always gives us this explanation
so now you may say okay this is a really
academic exercise right
why why would anyone want to do this but
let me
let me quickly motivate why this is i
think of really
practical relevance as well and for this
um
let's consider the following example
let's again consider this credit
assignment
task that we discussed earlier so a bank
tries to decide algorithmically whether
or not a customer
gets a loan or not and
and so let's imagine we are this
um there's this bank out there and it's
called the sexist bank of america and
basically what it does
is it uses an unethical uh strategy
for credit assignment it it basically
just looks at the gender of the
applicant
and if it's male then it grants a loan
and if it's not it rejects the loan
that's basically the strategy that it
uses
there's a tiny bit of income in the
classifier as well just to ensure that
it's not
um completely insensitive to the income
so that the income is a little bit
different every time
i think the outcome is a little bit
different every time depending on the
income
but this is really just a tiny
perturbation mainly it just
looks at the at the gender
and so if you run an explanation method
it would produce you some kind of
explanation which would look like
the one on the left this blue one
and um i've just switched the
visualization here
a little bit just because now it's
feature-based not pixel-based so i've
listed the three features
gender income and taxes and i assign
relevance which is normalized such that
the total relevance is one
and you can see basically all the
relevance is put on
gender so the explanation method shows
you
it makes transparent that an unethical
sexist
decision process is at work so you would
say
great right um so if the european union
requires by law
to specify to give these explanations
we would be able to pick up on these
kind of strategies
but what we show basically is that you
can construct
another classifier g twiddle which has
exactly the same classification results
for so for any given user it would not
matter
if you run g twittle or g that the
outcome would be exactly the same
but the explanations would be
drastically different now all the
relevance is completely shifted to the
financial features
and that's basically um why i think this
this result is worrisome and interesting
at the same time it basically shows that
these explanation methods as they
currently are are not a good
proof for uh for an un
for an ethical decision-making process
right they're basically
they can be manipulated
okay so uh i just wanted to comment
because i have this funny title
right fair washing explanations with off
manifold detergent that was the
name of the paper that we put out so
hopefully you have understood the first
part of this title now
fair washing explanations that's because
we
the original strategy was not fair and
then you can
fair wash it such the explanation gives
the appearance as if
the underlying strategy was fair that's
basically why we called it
fair washing explanations what you
probably haven't understood yet
um is why we fairwash with off manifold
detergent
and in order to understand this i need
to explain to you how we do this
manipulation
and so in the paper we do a lot of
differential geometry to
to show that there actually exists such
a g-twiddle and how we can
get it i will not do this here because i
think
it would just take too much time and
we don't want to take a one-year course
of differential geometry
that's probably not the purpose here so
um i
i just gonna motivate this give you the
intuition of
of why um we are
um we we are able to do this
and and and then you can go to the paper
and see okay so
in order to understand why this drastic
degree of manipulability
is possible um we we're going to
take a step back and think a little bit
about
what we are doing when we are doing uh
classification
and um so what we are doing is basically
um my most modern deep learning
and machine learning tasks what you
actually have is you have some data
and this data lives on a low dimensional
manifold embedded in a high dimensional
ambient space
so an example of this is again mnist
in mnist the i think the resolution of
the images is 28 by 28
pixels so these data points there are
vectors
in r 28 times 28 i don't know
what 28 times 28 is but it's a huge
number so it's a huge dimensional
vector space but then if you are
at if you are looking at a particular
mnist digit
you could just slightly rotate it or
translate it and it would still look
like a digit
so there's some local connectedness
between
these um images
at least locally and the dimensionality
of this
space that is locally connected and is
just the
um the you know the the set of all
images
in mnist is very low i mean estimates
are
order 10 that's like the estimates that
we have
so there's a huge dimension really high
dimensional embedding space and a very
low dimensional
data manifold on which the data points
actually live
another way of seeing this is if you
just randomly uniformly sample pixel
values you would just see something like
noise
um but you would never see something
like an mnist digit
and so that's another indication i
have we have two questions oh sorry yeah
i
uh you answered partially from sophie so
what do you mean by has the same result
on every data point is it referring to
find out that data set or is it valid
for any possible data point of an
enzyme infinite infinite continuous
space
um so um so our theoretical results
are really for the whole manifold
so it's exactly the same manifold
and then it depends a little bit on the
classifier that you're using if you're
using logistic regression you can
exactly construct this model so it has
exactly the same behavior on the entire
data manifold
not just the sampled space that we have
but really the entire data manifold
and for neural network we can only
approximately construct this
manipulated model and so we just
approximately have the same outputs but
to very good position so the the mean
square error between the outputs is like
something like
10 to the minus six i mean i would need
to look at the paper but it's very small
okay um okay we have a lot of questions
uh popping up so we also have uh from
koshi
uh uh not sure it makes sense but does
the work assume any smoothness
assumption assumption of the geometry
yes we do we do being different
yes okay so we are assuming technically
we are
so you need to look at the paper to
really see all the instances but one of
the assumptions is
that the data manifold is a smooth
manifold
that's a that's an assumption that we
made
i also get a question
uh from spicer under the european law
how does a company justify
classification is it using an
important image like you showed do we
have to go into a trouble of creating
a tlg how can we just send a fake
importance
image so i'm not a lawyer
so whatever i would say now take it with
a grain of salt right
don't don't see me if i'm saying
something wrong here
but my understanding is that right now
these details are still
clarified because right now you you can
basically
um uh get around this regulation by
saying
that there was some kind of human in the
loop if there was some kind of human in
the loop
you don't have to write this explanation
and so
now it gets a legal question it gets to
be a legal question about
what does it mean to have a human in the
loop and right now
my understanding is from talking to
people who
you know have analyzed this that the the
the definition of this is very liberal
so in practice
right now um you basically don't have to
worry about this
this is my understanding you should talk
to your lawyer if you want to be sure
um but um the european union is working
on a revised legislation and then it
will depend on the details
okay um i will i will go through the
other question
and tell me if you think that we should
go to the end for some also
from does the manipulate the
manipulation of explanations
apply also to other explanating methods
other than these local methods
um so we haven't tested other
uh global methods mainly because
they're there it's sort of built
training is built
into the explain explainability often
so you typically train a model such that
it has some
underlying understanding of concepts and
so forth so
it's it's it's a little bit of a
different
um way of approaching the question so
it doesn't fit into the framework but
what we did test
is that it holds about uh you know for a
lot of different
local explainability methods so you can
check the paper i think we had like
six explanation methods in there but we
also you know we just included six
because
you know at some point the paper you
have to have tables for all these
methods
um we tested it with more and at least
qualitatively it also
uh worked for the others that we checked
finally how is the information preserved
while approximating manifolds basically
how do you
quantify the information loss
yeah so um maybe we can talk about this
in the end because
i i i was planning on discussing how we
estimate the manifold
yeah so that's a great question all of
them were great questions thank you
um but i think this one will become
clear in just a second
if i have time for it and if not
please ask the question again um please
okay
cool well thanks so much it's good to
get some feedback so
um so um just remember
basically the upshot here is that the
data lives on a low dimensional manifold
in a high dimensional embedding space so
the technical term for this
is the manifold hypothesis it's this is
sort of the name that is assigned to
this phenomenon
and so now just to mentally picture this
we're going to draw
the ambient space as being
two-dimensional and the embedding
manifolds the data manifold as being
one-dimensional
that's not true in reality the data
manifold is much of much lower
dimensionality than the ambient space
but we cannot picture this so
we will stick to this mental picture
and now we're going to pick a particular
data point this red dot here
and remember that the heat map
as an explanation is of the same
dimensionality as the input
so it is a vector in the ambient space
right because the ambient space is the
the space of the inputs basically
and so we can attach this vector to the
to the data point just draw a little
error
and and now observe that the behavior
of the function on the data just
determines
the components of the gradient
along the data manifold so so in order
to understand why the gradient is
important just remember
that one of the explanation methods was
the gradient with respect to the input
right so the error that i've drawn here
for illustration is just the gradient
with respect
of to the input of the classifier g
and that's a vector in mb in space
and i can decompose this vector in two
components
oh no i need to
um the green one and the yellow one one
is parallel to the data manifold and one
is orthogonal to the data
mode and so now the gradient component
parallel to the data manifolds
is the only component that is relevant
for the behavior of the function along
the data manifold basically because
you just need to know what values the
function takes along the data manifold
right
in order to know its behavior on the
data and that determines the gradient
along the data
but the components orthogonal are
completely arbitrary for the behavior on
the data i can arbitrarily change them
it will not change the behavior on the
data
i hope this was clear if not please
interrupt me
and so basically what we do is we
manipulate these orthogonal components
off of the gradient in order to
manipulate the gradient explanation
because we can arbitrarily choose these
these these orange orthogonal components
we can basically arbitrarily choose an
orthogonal component
and thereby manipulate the gradient so
the explanation
and because they are much more
orthogonal components the explanation is
basically determined by the orthogonal
components
and so to very good position we can
reproduce any target
explanation map that's basically the
idea
so i hope this was clear in a paper we
really showed this with differential
geometry so we start from a function
defined on the data manifold and then we
show that we can extend it
with a and manipulate the gradient
orthogonal to the data
okay um so this is just saying what i
just said
and here are a few more pictures so um
we are seeing again c410 and we are
seeing um the original model and
manipulated model dtwiddle and
um and you you're seeing basically that
this manipulation works for several
different
explanation methods grad input times
grant and so forth if that
name if these names don't make sense to
you it's just different
exponential methods okay so i'm at
32 minutes i think um so i could stop
here or i could
quickly explain how we propose to
reduce the number of um that the degree
of manipulability i'm not sure
what time what the time frame is
uh okay we have another question but i
will propose to continue as we have the
question on the flow so
if some people want to
to ask questions they can directly do it
so
uh i'm there's another question at this
so question will they
there be any usefulness to uh to look at
second order gradients maybe
how the gradient changes if you change
the data
yeah this is something that we are
investigating a little bit there is some
degree
of manipulability for the second order
gradients as well
because essentially again you are just
fixing the function
on the data manifold right this is the
function on the data manifold is fixed
but
the orthogonal components are not fixed
and so if you calculate the second order
gradient
um the hessian then some a lot of these
components of the hessians are of the
hessian is not
fixed um just by knowing the function on
the data
but there are there are components that
are fixed
and so you could look at these the
problem is it's harder to visualize
right
with like the gradient you can really
show this heat map so it's
something that you can intuitively grasp
but with higher order
um uh derivatives it's harder to picture
that's basically a problem
um so so maybe i just quickly explained
so
in the paper we also propose a method to
reduce
the amount of manipulability that you
can do and i quickly gonna
explain this it will take like three
minutes um
i should say up front it's not the most
practical one it's more like
something that we can work towards and
make
like aim to make it work at scale but it
gives additional proof to this mental
picture that i
outlined here and basically the idea
here is
um you know the orthogonal components of
the gradients
were arbitrary right we could chose that
we could choose them at will
but the components parallel to the data
manifold
were not arbitrary so our idea was to
basically project the explanation
on the components parallel to the data
manifolds
now the question is that or the problem
that makes it so hard to do this
is basically that we don't know any
analytic form of the data manifold we
just have samples right and we need to
infer the structure of the data manifold
from these samples
and so this makes a connection to a
whole other field in machine learning
which is called manifold learning
i'm not going to in to go into details
here i just gonna give you the most
basic
algorithm that there is to estimators
and
this can be used on mnist for example
and so the basic idea is here you pick a
data point for which you want to
calculate the exponential method
then you look at the k nearest neighbors
and you fit a hyperplane through these
neighbors and this gives you some
estimate of the tangent space
and then you project the explanation on
this tangent space
that's basically the idea right and so
if you do this
so you project it and this is the result
if you do this for
c410 so basically this is the
original model and this is the
manipulated model and the explanations
before here for the manipulated model
looked like a 42
and now they look very similar to the
unmanipulated model there's still some
degree of difference due to the
um well one reason is that we don't
estimate the manifold perfectly but it's
it the manipulability is is basically
the manipulated thing
goes away and it's also harder to attack
directly
okay so uh i'm over time so i i just
gonna summarize here
um so what i've tried to convince you
off
is that explainability methods as they
stand local explainability methods
are vulnerable to a very serious degree
of
manipulability so specifically we can
construct for any classifier g we can
track
construct another classifier gtl which
has exactly the same behavior on the
data
manifold but has an arbitrary
explanation
and in principle you could try to get
around this by projecting the
explanations
on tangent space the problem with this
is you need to estimate tangent space
and for high dimensional data sets such
as imagenet this is an extremely costly
task and something that is still very
much an
active research topic okay
well thank you very much
for the german we
we just got a question
from alaska how is information preserved
while
uh approximating manifolds basically how
do you quantify the information box with
respect to original data samples
yeah so i mean um
there are two problems here one is um
we don't have the entire data manifold
in practice right
i mean you can construct toy models
where you where you know the data
manifold and
there are also some robotics tasks where
you know what the manifold will look
like
but for image classification for example
we just have samples
of the underlying data distribution and
the task is now to infer the structure
of the manifold from these samples
and this is inherently ill-defined right
because if you wanted to construct
a manifold which goes perfectly through
these points you would get
some a lot of solutions and many of them
are really wiggly
and and so you know you need to come up
with some kind of regularization scheme
but it's just
that the underlying problem is it's it's
it's a task
that has no unique solution and and you
can hope that you can somehow
you know that is the typical problem of
machine learning so this is one problem
and then the other problem is that even
if we knew the underlying data manifold
perfectly
it's still a very computational
intensive task
right and and so we will never fit
tangent space perfectly
and so these two sources very much lead
to information loss
right it's not that we can perfectly
estimate tangible space and we
because we can it's a very difficult
problem but also we cannot perfectly
estimate the manifolds
so yes that's very much an information
last time
um i got a good question from helena
assumed that the sexist bank simply
replaced it modeled by the non-sexist
chief
tilt will that mean that both models are
equally good and there is also no
problem with the sexist model
so so um the the
the model g and the model g turtle
they they have the same performance on
the data set
right they they really they give the
same like if you go there and you submit
your
your credit um form you will get the
same answer back
exactly the same probabilities i mean in
this case if you do a logistic
regression which is the most
straightforward thing that you would do
there you really get exactly the same
thing there's no approximation
involved and so the behavior on the data
manifold is exactly the same
what is not um the same is the
explanation
right and and so the
somehow um the the bank can still run
exactly the same strategy because it's
um well if it wants to um
but but the the heat map is really not
displaying
that that the strategy is used and
that's the danger right because
if you naively um apply these heat maps
you would think that this is impossible
and
you would take these heat maps as a
proof that the bank is not following the
strategy
of course in this particular case you
could it's just three features right so
you could just
to you know shoot different um
um proposals at the bank and see that
this is basically the strategy but in
reality you're not using three features
you're using much more
right and so this you you can hide this
in more subtle ways
oh great um sorry i'm going through
and i get a question so
the explanation g seems to be uh
what we will expect intuitively is is
maybe
is it maybe either maybe a measure like
entropy of the different explanation i
have the intuition explain
entity explanation special in some case
some cases yeah i mean uh of course if
you i mean
um if you pick very crazy target
explanations
i mean that's a really good point and
then of course
the answers are so nonsensical that
it will be like you can always go back
in in the case of the credit assignment
task right you could always go back and
just try it out if you have three
features you can just try it out
and so if the if the if the target
explanation is chosen completely crazy
then there are probably ways to check
this but um
if the input becomes really high
dimensional and your
target heat map is a little bit more
subtle then
it may be hard and and um there's now
there are now more and more papers on
the subject
of trying to detect these kind of
manipulations
and i i expect this to be something that
people will work on over the next years
and hopefully we will come up with some
kind of
good algorithmic modifications which
we'll be able to pick up on these
manipulations and entropy might be one
way to go
uh so question also from henry
i think it's uh also in this question
could you dictate matriculation based on
the autograph components
so um
yes so this is an idea that we have also
been exploring up a little bit i mean
basically because the orthogonal
components
are not determined by training you could
try
to look at them and look if they look
like noise
right you would expect if they're not
determined and the training
process does not try to manipulate them
they should
look a little bit like noise but
so i think that would be a strategy to
to look at this but
the problem is in practice you need to
estimate tangent space right and for
mnist
or c5 you can still do this but for for
higher dimensional data sets it's just
not feasible at the moment
and so then you cannot really do this
decomposition
and so for low dimensional data sets i
think that's a good strategy but for
high dimensional data sets
it's it's just not something that we can
do at the moment that may change
okay any other questions we might have
time for
one or two otherwise i had one
but um i also have one
sort of a silly question maybe uh those
are the best questions actually
in your presentation you presented
really
nicely to like as an
image like the explanation was given to
us as an image is it like a heat map
so my question would be could we use
some type of image classifier that
classifies the right explanation
in a sense i mean imagine you have
some data set and the data set gives you
some heat map
which is an explanation but on the other
hand we know exactly which explanation
is the true one or this could be
politically mandated which explanation
is good
and then we could just apply some type
of image classifier which says hey
is this explanation um modified or is it
the actual explanation that is supposed
to come out
yeah so so i mean like there there was a
very interesting
paper at icml this year which basically
trained so it was something called along
the lines of
right for the right reasons or something
and so what they did is they basically
trained a classifier in such a way
that it not only got the right
classification results but they
also ensured that the heat maps looked
sensible so they
had some human uh operator who drew some
heat maps
basically they said well in this region
most of the heat must be assigned
and then they train the algorithm such
that the heat maps look
um correctly and
and um and um that that was interesting
i i
i found because i mean in in some tasks
they also showed that this helps with
generalization
um this was a very specific task i don't
think that you can expect this on
imagenet
but in this very specific task it was a
scientific
task i think related to skin cancer
it helped with generalization but
yeah i'm not sure if that is the general
thing i would doubt it
so maybe the paper was called
differently i'm not i'm not quite sure
if it was called right for the right
reasons it's sort of
a need to look up what the precise title
okay
um i think
we will finish i just want to conclude
um to say
a big thank you um well thank you
that was really great um so
i will stop the recording now
and so we have a small break